[Music]
my name is malcolm barrett
i'm a clinical research data scientist
at teledoc health
i'm an epidemiologist and i'm also an r
developer
i use our packages every day in my work
and they're also fundamental to the way
that i organize my code
and the reason for that is that our
packages are the fundamental unit
of shareable code in r
they solve many of our problems for us
they make our code
more robust easier to share and much
safer over time
whether that's somebody that's using it
in the future that we've shared it with
or it's just us in six months right
our code is less likely to break in that
time because of the robustness of our
packages
and yet many people when they encounter
the idea of writing our package they
think
this is too advanced for me this is
beyond my scope
this is beyond my skill set many people
also think that they don't have
something to offer
they think that if they're not writing
something like gigipatu or dplyr
something that's really incredible then
they don't have anything to offer
anything to share i'd like to tell you a
story that comes from buddhism
once there was a father and a son and at
some point the father and the son got
separated
here their lives diverged dramatically
the father became quite wealthy he
developed a huge estate
and amassed a great amount of riches the
son
on the other hand became absolutely
destitute
he was embodying poverty
later on in their lives the son actually
stumbled upon the father's estate
now the son didn't recognize the father
the father had changed so much in his
riches that he was unrecognizable
but the father even though his son was
draped in poverty
recognized the son immediately he tried
to bring him into the house
to say look look you can have all of
this
and the son thought he was crazy he
tried to run of the house
he thought this guy is nuts i don't want
anything to do with this
so the father sent his servants to go
after the son
and hire him instead as an employee of
the the estate
the son worked his way up from the very
bottom until
many years later to the very top of the
estate at this point
he's the right hand man of his father
on his deathbed the father finally
reveals to the son
who he is that in fact everything that's
around him
is already his and in some versions of
the story
at this point the sun says that he
actually
has already already understood that he
has naturally come to understand
that what surrounds him is his wealth
his treasure
something that is
of himself
this is a talk about why you already
have the skill set
from the techniques that you use every
day in your data analysis
to pursue the path of our package
development
in a zen text called the sandokai
there's a saying
if you do not see the way you do not see
it even as you walk on it
this is to say that we're actually
always already perfect and complete
already ready so in r we might say
if you don't see the r package you do
not see it even as you develop it
for instance you already structure your
project
now in our package has a very specific
structure that it uses
and yours might look something like this
your project i've got a data folder
a reports folder and a scripts folder an
analysis folder
now in our packages specifically uses a
folder called
r with a capital r it also uses a data
folder
just as it is instead of a report we
might have a vignette
a long form documentation as well as a
number of other files that are formal
but help us do things that we actually
often do in our analysis
describe it test it and provide
information about how it works
the use this package is really useful in
connecting the abilities that we already
have that we use
in our work to this formalized structure
of using
in our package so as you might imagine
one of the most useful functions that
this pet this project
this package has is to create a package
using the create package function
so here i'm creating a package called
zen art art packages
and it's laying out all of this
infrastructure that i need
to use in our package and it's doing it
all for me automatically
it's also communicating to me very
concretely very
simply what it what it's actually doing
and if i need to do anything
one of the most important files that it
creates is the description
file the description file is going to
tell you
what the package does what it's called
who wrote it who contributed to it
what the license is and it might tell
you some more about dependencies
and more along those lines it's also a
really amazing file because it's sort of
a golden ticket
it gives you access to many of the
really excellent tools
in the r ecosystem for developing our
packages tools like use this
and dev tools for instance
use this also has a function called
create
project and while this uses a formalized
structure it's much
much simpler compared to an r package it
does create an r studio project
but it doesn't have a lot of this other
top level stuff that organizes in our
package
notably it doesn't have a description
file
but we can add one to it using use
description
and what happens when i add a
description file to a project that
actually isn't a package
use this still treats it as if it is a
package
and so that means that we can tap into
some of the tools that we're going to
talk about about writing tests
and other tools that we're not going to
talk about like writing documentation
quite easily because use this
and dev tools will actually treat your
project
as if it's a package
you also already write our code
now your r code might look something
like this here i'm taking iris i'm
grouping it and i'm summarizing it
and it's resulting in a data frame this
is something that i do every day in my
work
and if i use use this i can put it this
code in a formal place using user
this will create an r folder for me if
it doesn't exist already
and put my code into it as well as open
up this file for me to write code in
instead of just writing my code plainly
i'm actually going to wrap it in a
function
functions being what you would expect in
our package to export
so here i'm creating summarize iris and
i'm putting it in the file that i just
opened
now one of the things that's really
great about having a package or a
project with a description file
in it is tapping into the devtools
ecosystem
devtools has this function called
loadall that has a key binding in
rstudio that makes it a little bit
easier
and what it does is it looks in that r
folder and it's going to load the
functions
that are in your package or your project
into your session
as if you had sourced that as if you had
sourced
an r code script and so now i have
summarize iris available to me and i can
run it in my console or in another
script quite easily
you may not realize it but you also
already declare your
your dependencies for instance if i have
code like this
it often begins with a series of library
calls and really what i'm saying is
for this code to work i need the type
the dplyr library and i need the ggplot2
library
otherwise this function is not going to
run correctly
in a package we can declare dependency
by using the use
package function so here i'm saying use
package d plier
use this as adding it to the description
file and then it's telling me that i
have something to do
whenever i use a function from this
package i need to
preface it with dplyer colon colon i
need to specif
really specify which namespace this
function is coming from
and then i'll also do the same for gt.2
because of course my code
also depends on this package
so now when i have my function i need to
include
the names of these packages as well as
the double colon
so this function ends up looking a
little bit more like this where i'm
adding dplyer colon colon
and then the name of the function that
comes from dplyr and the same for gdpr2
what also is changing is my description
file
what previously looked like this now has
two extra lines
d plier and ggplot are part of the
import section
and this is where that magic happens
when you install an r package
you'll notice that when you install an r
package you don't have to manually go
and install
every other package that that package
uses are
smart enough to look at this file and
install those
those packages for you and so that's
exactly what happens when you install
package from crayon
or from github or from another source i
will actually go and look for these
packages and install them for you
you can also use depth tools to install
them manually using the installed apps
function which is extremely useful
now you may not realize this part in
particular but you also already test
your code
this might be one where you're thinking
wait a minute i don't
really even know what testing your code
means i'm not a software engineer i
don't i don't
write unit tests when i do my analysis i
don't test my code
but actually we test our code every day
often in a situation like this
i've got this function clean data and
i'm giving it the irs data set
and something obviously has gone wrong
here right it's giving me an error
and i don't quite know what the problem
is so i actually need to sit around and
think about it a little bit
usually at this point i start fiddling
around in my counsel
to see if i can actually make it work
right i will
give it a different data set or change a
few things or look at my code and really
try to understand
why isn't this working so i go back and
forth i really iterate through this
process to try and get it working
and it turns out in this case if for
some reason i remove the fifth column
it actually works my data is now clean
but that just makes me think more
why is that right and so i'm gonna again
go through that iterative process
of figuring out what's wrong with my
code how can i get it to work what do i
expect it to look like and what does it
look like right now
what you're doing is doing a a unit test
of your code you just aren't writing it
down
and so the process of writing unit tests
is to formalize this iterative process
of kicking the tire of our code to
making sure that it works the way that
we expect
now unfortunately often the way we do
this analysis is when it breaks
but writing unit tests helps you write
code more robustly because it
helps you kick the tires all around the
car not just in the tire that has a leak
the use test function will help you
create
a test in the right spot set up all the
infrastructure that you need
from the test that package which is one
of the most popular testing libraries
in r put everything in its right place
open up for this file for you
and set it up so that you can automate
your tests so if i go and i write
the informal test that i just did in the
command line
directly in a test script i can now
run the test function from dev tools
also which has a very convenient
key binding in rstudio it will load the
package for me and will run all my tests
and now i can know if i make a change to
my code that
everything is still okay i've got a
green light still or
importantly if i don't i know what's
wrong and where it comes from
there are great many ways that you can
use the arm package
system to extend what you already do in
your analysis
but these are three really useful
techniques that you can really get off
the ground with
the first is using a description file
this lets you
provide metadata about your project or
your package it lets you tell us what
your dependencies are
and it gives you access to this whole
ecosystem
such as loading and testing that is
available to you when you're developing
an r package
write your code as functions you're
already using functions in your everyday
work
so this step is to actually take that
wrap it in your own function
and finally write down the tests that
you're actually already doing
and then automate them take advantage of
the description file
of this ecosystem for our packages
and automate this process what would be
the next step
in coming home to our packages taking
advantage of this treasure that's
already yours
we put together a workshop called my
organization's first r package that's
really focused on developing
internal r packages personal r packages
things for you
your team your research group things
like that
so i recommend checking out this
resource and i also highly highly
recommend
looking into the second edition of the r
packages book in particular the first
chapter
which is called whole game walks you
through the whole process of creating
our package from a to z and it's great
and will help you get off the ground
right away
so this is my invitation to you
right in our package whether it's for
your own personal use that you'll never
share with anybody else
perhaps for your team perhaps changing a
project into a package
or creating a package to help with a
project or maybe you've got a great idea
that you want to develop out into
a package that you're actually going to
share with lots of people and maybe even
submit to crayon
this is my invitation to you is to try
this out walk this path
and take advantage of this incredible
resource
that's already available to you with the
skill set that you already have
trungpa rinpoche a tibetan buddhist
teacher had good news and bad news for
us
in our meditation practice the first
the bad news is that you're falling out
of an airplane
you don't have anything to hang on to
you don't have a parachute
and things seem pretty bad but the good
news is
actually there's no ground
there's no way that you can fail at this
process
my name is malcolm barrett you can find
me on twitter github
and my website thank you for coming and
good luck
you